stop waiting on other people and instead
hustle while you wait hey guys welcome
to the book update video and one of the
things that I find to be super common
with entrepreneurs is we hate waiting
and generally hate waiting where
hustlers we we like to get stuff done I
think it holds a lot of entrepreneurs
back from getting into partnerships or
hiring a team because you want to do
everything yourself because you know
your company because you know you can
get it done and we're generally
frustrated with people who don't work at
our pace who can't give us results when
we want results because we know that we
could do that better and I think one of
the things that you have to deal with as
an entrepreneur one of the most
frustrating things is Bill B times we
have to wait for people whether it's a
customer who's you know waiting to sign
a deal whether it's a partner who you're
waiting on getting some work done
whether it's an employee wouldn't finish
a project its media who said that they
would get an article up and it hasn't
launched yet you're going to have to end
up waiting for people the key thing
though is going to be how you react to
it you can't control other people's
times other people's schedules to a
certain extent and how you react to it
is going to be the important part and so
you know as an entrepreneur you gotta
hustle while you wait while you're
waiting on this project that happened if
you can't do anything else to make a
move you're not just sitting around
twiddling your thumbs doing something
else you're you're making action happen
right maybe in a different part of your
business but you are hustling always not
just waiting for something else to
happen from somebody else right and so
how does relate to the book it's raining
a book out postponed instead of wanting
october they wanted in january fine you
know i made a video about that and if
they want to cope be ready do one and
Jamie would be ready and instead of just
waiting for genuine out to come along
I'm making it better I'm hustling I'm
looking to add in an illustrator to join
the team to help create some awesome
graphics for the book I'm looking at
adding an extra story to the book that I
was on the fence of whether i should add
somebody else or not now i have the
extra times are gonna go and do that and
so i'm adding to make it better I'm
hustling while I'm waiting right I'm not
just waiting for jenna to come along and
you have to do that for your business
again you cannot control most people's
schedules the only thing he controls
your reaction to the weight so stop
waiting
start hustling while you wait let's get
to your questions so last week I asked
you guys to a bunch of questions and you
delivered with a tons i'm going to go
through them quickly first up to Mary
weeks it seems impossible to get eight
chapters done by October how long does
it take you to turn a rough draft into a
chapter of the 10 chapters about the
same length that's a great question and
I think each chapter has taken different
amounts of time it really depends on how
much external research I need to do a
lot of the concepts I've already had in
my head for years and it's therefore
easy for me to just put it down on paper
but when I need to go out and find
examples to kind of prove the point or
you know I have an example of mine but
it doesn't quite fit or I need to go and
do more research basically if I'm if I'm
if I have to rely on other people if I
could do an interview and I'm waiting on
that it takes longer for the chapters
that come together each chapter is not
all the same length I haven't really
been monitoring that I don't know how
much that matters each chapter is
basically as long as it needs to be just
like how long should a youtube video be
how long should your web copy be how
long should your newsletter be it should
be as long as it needs to be to get your
point across not more not less and so
each chapter in the book in my views as
long as it needs to be next up new
future build a great video in terms of
setting your schedule how do you like to
manage your energy especially while
writing and editing where does your time
energy management balance fall so that's
an interesting question I think in the
morning I tend to do the stuff that I do
for the day so I like to get that done
first I start off my day where I'm doing
the comments I like from you guys I'm
reviewing my videos that are going up
for the day the kind of mean stuff that
I have to do for the day and then from
about noon on is whatever project I'm
doing for that day so as an example it's
just past noon I just laughed I'm
walking the whole foods now it's my book
writing day the morning have my routine
everything I do in the morning and now
it's noon on and that's how I kind of
manage and I go until about five spend
some time with Hayden and then the pain
was happening during the night so I
guess I do the routine stuff mostly in
the morning because it's before the day
might explode on me or something might
happen and then the daily things each
day is a different day that happens from
noon on next up Rishi Cup TV hey Evan
great hearing your updates and with a
coin the new company
I wish you the best and adjusting your
schedule I'm happy you're cooking
breakfast for Nina in the mornings too
she deserves it haha followed up by
Tamara who said yeah Nina deserves
breakfast and a packed lunch okay guys i
agree i love supporting Nina I'm gonna
do it more don't give her encouragement
okay I don't need the extra aggravation
but thank you for the support next up
Chris we know a printer locally and they
do a good job my question is is it wise
to skip to normal publisher we don't
have money for a publisher summer
dresses issue a couple times should you
get a publisher or not I think really it
depends on what your motivation is for
the book what your goal is to the book
if your goal is just to have a book out
you know you cross it off your bucket
list then great you'll need a publisher
just go and self publish it yourself if
your goal is to have a big impact to
reach a big audience then you might be
able to do that yourself but that's
where a publisher could be handy so for
me my goal has never been about the
money it's not about how much money can
I make from a book because if you get a
lot of sales you'll probably make more
from self-publishing than you would go
in with the traditional publisher but I
want to reach I want the awareness I
want the impact my goal is to help a
billion entrepreneurs and so being able
to leverage a publisher I find will help
me get to that goal faster than if I
just tried to do it on your own so what
are your intentions right if you want to
make more money and if you want just to
have a book out then don't go with a
publisher but if you want to have impact
when I have reach you want to be able to
to make a connection with a lot of
people then I would go with the
publisher next up cardigan Jane do you
plan on diversifying with an audiobook
at audible since they are owned by
amazon kindle there are great resources
across promote and expand your audience
by the way you have some awesome
marketing ideas if you want to connect
I'm always open to awesome marketing
ideas so let me know audio book i would
say probably I'm totally open and down
to reading an audiobook version
that comes out I haven't honestly
thought that far ahead it's right now
more about just creating the book making
it something awesome making something
I'm proud of something I want to show my
grandkids make it something that I think
will impact a lot of people point all my
heart damaging to that and once that
part is done then I'll be focusing on
how do i market this and so thank you
for the suggestion definitely open to
opportunities right now it's just book
writing mode next up is a backstop pace
how do you balance your family in your
business I've chosen the path of a
professional footballer and this
requires a lot of time and energy all
while I'm finishing up my school my
mother keeps complaining i'll spend
enough time with her maybe she's right
but she's so negative and always
complaining about something i can't deal
with that negative energy what should i
do your book will be great by the way so
thank you for that book plug there at
the end it's a tough one I think as
entrepreneurs we need to there's always
an issue about work-life balance and
when somebody is negative man I hate
having negative energy in my life as a
general rule and you need to cut out the
negative people around you I would
honestly if it were me try to have an
honest conversation with her and say why
you're doing this why it's important
help her be a part of your dream instead
of feeling like she's on the outside I
think a lot of parents obviously want to
see their kids be successful a lot of
them have given up on their own dreams
stop thinking that they could do
anything powerful and meaningful in the
world and so they get to live
vicariously through your life so you
become a successful you reach in your
dreams you doing something big makes
them feel happy and if they're not a
part of that then I'm going to feel left
out they're going to complain they're
going to be feeling like they're on the
sidelines and they're not important and
so I would try to be involved and have
her feel like she's a part of your
success thank her and tell her what
you're doing tell her what you're up to
even if it's not visiting may be on time
to visit in person maybe it's a phone
call maybe to email and in return for
that she's got to be positive you can
let I know you don't need negativity in
your life you don't want this to be part
of what you're doing because it's
holding you back from you
and I think that honest conversation
would help I hope it does but again I am
NOT the family expert necessarily it's
just how I would manage things
personally the light is turning the
orange and I need to run run run run run
run run run okay next the legend for all
what's new business you're opening I
will let you guys in on that once
everything is official it is taking up a
chunk of my time and it's coming soon I
plans to let you guys know cardigan Jane
with another question are you self
publishing also ordered a marketing
strategy to reach your niche once
published what expected profit margin to
be once it's completed so I address that
not publishing working with penguin
Random House marketing strategy is going
to be using my network using my YouTube
audience using my newsletter doing
interviews again it's not super well
plan or thought out because it's still a
year you go with a publisher write my
book is going to be delivered to them in
January now and won't be released till
like the next January so I've got a year
to figure all that out what do you
expect your profit margin to be I don't
care like the profit margin is not why
I'm doing this it's the furthest thing
from my mind will it make money yeah
probably will it make a ton of money if
a ton of money is your game then being
an author is not where you want to be a
business model coming from writing books
is typically from everything that comes
around it right you get speaking gigs
you get corporate games you can create
products it's building awareness for
your brain and what you're doing and so
how much you make from the book I don't
know it's inconsequential that'll make
money but a lot more money will come
from all the other stuff they do as a
result of it and of even greater
importance to me is it being able to
reach a lot of people have an impact on
lines that's why I'm doing it otherwise
I do a million other things because
write in the book is one of the longest
hardest things you're going to do
and if your focus is on the money you're
gonna give up next up king j do you have
things in your schedule you don't like
to do that's my business grows I notice
I'm having more and more things am I
schedule that I just don't want to do
but I know it's required for growth how
do I schedule it so I can get through
the things I don't want to do I
personally have 10 things scheduled for
tomorrow and want to do two of those
things thanks looking forward to the
book great question and I would start at
a higher level and understand and really
absorb that if you are consistently
doing things that you do not like doing
love doing makes you come alive there's
no way you're gonna be able to build a
great company you do not build great
businesses by doing things that you are
not or cannot become great at that's
just how it is and so if you are doing
eighty percent of the tasks that you're
doing or things that you don't like that
you're never going to be great at you
got to get those off your plate I think
that's actually honestly most
entrepreneurs you only have twenty
percent of your time if that focus on
the big picture stuff the stuff that you
love the stuff that you're great at the
stuff that will make your business or
and you're spending eighty percent plus
your time doing the crack of just
running the business and so as quickly
as possible you want to eliminate auto
automate delegate look at those tasks do
you actually have to get those done if
not eliminate them next can you automate
them can you get software can you get
tools why are you still doing your books
in Excel just yet software to help you
do it and then delegate get somebody to
help you overseas it could be five bucks
an hour the first person I hired was to
work one hour a day for me to alleviate
some of the tasks that are on my plate
get used to hiring people delegating
tasks out and so that frees up time for
you to build focus on the big picture
sub to help you grow your business next
up tahira I haven't written an official
book yet aside from ebooks and fiction
on the side but I have a question for
you I know you mentioned at Tuesday's
your book-writing day but have you ever
tried to set aside some time on a daily
basis to write see an hour or two every
day I right Delia Mac operator and I
find this helps keep me sharp and
shields my scribe muscles from atrophy
hashtag unforgettable hashtag believe
this is great and I think honestly you
have to create a routine that works for
you one of the challenges that I find in
writing a book as opposed to writing
your blog posts are writing some tweets
or writing for social media it's a big
project and it often will take me 30 to
45 minutes just to get back into it to
remember where I left off what I was
thinking and what I was talking about it
can take me 45 minutes to an hour just
to get back into flow of where I was
before and I left off so if I was doing
an hour a day I'd never get anything
great done because my great work doesn't
happen in the first hour it happens
afterwards and so I find that's the same
on any big project and maybe that's just
me and that's maybe why I've made my
schedule so that I have massive chunks
of time to dedicate to important
projects because if I only had an hour
to do something then I probably wouldn't
get anything great done and so that's
what I find helps I try doing starting
the day with you know breakfast and
getting some writing done and it just
felt like spent so much time reviewing
and I never ended up writing anything
that I love and so that's why I moved it
to the afternoon once a week and really
chunking that out so that works for me
but if you found something that works
for you do that you know you can
experiment and play with it but just
because I'm doing tilton doesn't mean
you have to next I said I want to be a
writer but procrastination is a big
factor can you make a video on how to
overcome procrastination really first up
is figuring out do you actually love
this right the stuff that you love doing
makes you come alive you can't wait to
get out of bed and start doing it you
stay up late because you're doing it
like I would challenge do you actually
want to become a writer why do you want
to do that is because somebody said it
looked good or because you know you see
authors and you think they're living the
life is this something that is actually
who you are or something that you just
pretend to want to be I think that's a
big difference because you can schedule
things in you can make a plan and say
okay three times a week I'm going to
schedule this time in to be a writer and
work on that dream but you can only
force yourself to do something that you
don't like for so long before you
realize that this isn't working and so
if you've always wanted to be writer but
you've never taken action on it I'd
really examine like what is holding you
back is it a limiting belief is it the
fact that you really just don't love it
enough is that
you don't have anything else in your
life that you want to do that makes you
come alive this is what you default it
to you got to figure that out because
it's not the scheduling because when you
love something when it makes you come
alive you will find the time to make it
happen next up sharing who writes in to
say I wake up every morning and espresso
keeps me going I love that song too it's
awesome by the way what program are you
using to write your pumpkin so I started
off using word and that was super easy
for me I had it offline i could take it
anywhere i needed and then as I started
involving people on my team we needed a
more flexible solution because if I
edited it and someone else was editing
at the same time wouldn't work so we
switched to google docs that's what
we're using right now so a bunch of us
have access to it and we can look at it
you can see who's editing what at what
time it updates you with alerts at some
point it's got to get to the publisher
and I honestly don't know what format
they wanted in if Google Docs is even
something they use but it's usually
pretty flexible to be able to export it
to whatever we need and so we've
actually created a chapter each chapter
is its own google doc so we can go
through and make changes and edits and
it's easy to keep on top of and you can
also download it locally so if you have
Google Drive you can have a local copy
so if I make changes when I'm offline it
connects automatically syncs so that's
where using it's working pretty well me
pick sir why not use this camera and
microphone for all your videos quality
is so much better and therefore more
enjoyable to watch so I was referring to
my video from last week where I didn't
have time to film on my ipod and that's
that's what's done with Jason and he's
my usual video guy and we felt most of
the videos on my channel using that
camera I like having a little bit of
variety you know I like being able to
talk to you while I'm on my way to write
in my book when I'm in books on mode and
uh you guys accompany me I'm I walk the
whole foods I don't know I like it on
the weekend ones too it's usually some
personal video Nina cooks or some
traveling video bike behind me
and I film goes off of my other camera
my big camera and I like the variety man
I'm sorry you don't like these videos as
much the content is still there it's
still quality and I'm gonna keep doing
it as long as I like it which way is
better to write daily weekly schedules
on a computer and phone or on paper
thank you that's a really interesting
one I do both and it really just depends
on how I'm feeling I'm a big believer in
just going with your flow I often find
that when I'm thinking I like to have
something on paper I just want to give
me a little more flexibility to be able
to draw create arrows in circles and I
find them just a little more creative
when I'm on paper in terms of creating
it but then when it comes to actually
following it I put it on my computer
because it just is so much easier for me
to maintain and I follow that calendar
almost religiously as religiously as I
can that's what I do so I'm actually
curious to know what you guys do do you
do paper or do you do computer leaving
the comments below last question no name
11 I like to ask you for advice if you
can make a minute or two to help me out
I'm a blogger and my contact goes out
every Monday Wednesday Friday I struggle
a lot with writing new content promoting
it do you think it'd be good if I would
promote only those days when you
articles go on the site and right on the
other three days I'm also writing the
book so I need a lot of time the right
but promotion is what I need for people
to see me thank you in advance this is a
fantastic question and more and more and
more and more and more what I've
discovered is if you're writing
something that's quality if you are
creating quality content whether it's
writing a blog whether it's creating
videos you don't need to do nearly as
much promotion as you used to because
people share it it's never been easier
to get your content to spread at any
other point in human history and so I
look at my youtube channel as an example
I do zero promotion on my youtube
zero you know I link it up so it goes to
my Twitter when a new video comes out
and I might put a couple videos in my
newsletter but for the most part it just
grows right a little bit of work
thinking about what the title is going
to be to make it a little more search
engine friendly that's a really loud
truck but if I had to think about where
to spend my time again you want to think
about what are you really good at and I
love creating the content for you guys
and that's where I spend my time I could
make fewer videos and then spend more
time on the promotion but I'd rather
spend the time in creating the content
and the channel is taken off right we've
got 120,000 odd subscribers growing at
an insane rate you know over 10 million
views on the channel all without any
real promotion and so if your posts
aren't taking off honestly when I start
to look at is are you actually creating
stuff that people care about or any of
your posts getting lift because of the
quality of the content and if they're
not instead of going out and promoting
them I try to think how can i make my
content better how could I improve
myself as a writer how can I create
stuff that moves people to the point
where they loved it so much that they
have to tell their friends and share it
because if you have some pieces like
that and you're an amazing writer I
guarantee you people will share it
that's what I do take a hard look at
myself and say am I an amazing writer
and how can I improve and beat on my
craft to get better so I don't have to
worry about the promotion side it'll
take care of itself take care of itself
because your content is that
so thank you guys so much for watching
tons of questions this week keep them
coming let me know if you have a
question they're going to answer in next
week's video ideally somewhat related to
this video or my book or the book
writing process or your book let me know
leave a comment continue to believe my
arms are getting tired from holding this
thing up high all the time getting the
workout here thank you guys I'll see you
see